imagine like if women were seeing this
song I know right like maybe a couple of
them even hmm maybe it like a really
emotional point in the show I get a
breakthrough of some kind
none of our ideas ever come true though
we must just have terrible ideas we just
have terrible ideas what's going on
reject nation Greg Alda here jonald as
you guys have heard us say before one of
our reward tiers on patreon whatever
video you're requesting must definitely
cover would I be a reaction or a video
discussion or a reaction in it's a
reaction today
it comes from Lewis bridge Lewis
beverage who is from Manchester England
this guy is a very very passionate
mathematician a teacher we've talked
quite a bit and this guy really does
have a love and enthusiasm and a heart
to empower the youth and to be the best
teacher he could possibly be sometimes
the last people what their passion in
life is and they can be a little bit
Wiggly about how they answer that but
this guy man he breaks it down even
knows where his passion stems from at
age 16 this whole life event that
happened say analytical side the
analytical side of his math brain
working Louis I gotta tell you I hope to
meet you in person one day because I
need tutoring even though yeah much
better math very I forgot how to add you
know you might live in England and you
might be a passionate teacher but I
think a person like you is willing to
help the youth that much somehow affects
society as a whole so thank you for your
contribution and today he wants to check
out a local band not our local and LA
local and Manchester boomin defying
gravity is a cover of a wicked song it's
a pretty wicked song let's do it
[Music]
look it's the one about the Mormons
right yeah the book of lying
yeah and spider-man wrote it yeah
[Music]
there's no one there
[Music]
whoa even the rubber sinks yeah
[Music]
that looks very hard yeah
[Music]
[Music]
there's a key
[Music]
[Music]
and they hear each other
[Music]
[Music]
tampo shift
[Music]
I think he's got the lyrics written on
the snare I can't believe they wrote all
those lyrics I know and arranged it so
so theatrically I feel like you can see
that on like a stage oh yeah with like a
whole bunch of other songs to go around
it maybe like some set pieces and things
maybe special sex yeah maybe you like
have like a broomstick scenario where it
like rises above the stage and it's
really impressive cuz you're like oh
this is live theater and like I'm not
used to seeing that ha ha but you know
the stuff we say that would be cool that
they did it they usually don't don't I
would love to see a cover of this by
females on a stage I don't know if
that's possible
you know so don't get your hopes up I
won't unless it comes back to the
Pantages a serious note seriously I've
heard this wicked song I think it's one
of two wicked songs I've heard I didn't
know by title but once they started I'm
like oh yeah I know this song it's
definitely one of them one of the famous
songs if a Broadway show can have a
single it's one of the singles for sure
it would be kind of challenging to tell
me oh yeah there's this male group in
England who is a rock version of this
gravity song yeah I would go okay and I
I'm sure that's cool for wicked fans but
hearing it and like they made it their
own if I had not heard that song before
and if I was not told them the title
that this was a cover of a wicked song I
would just assume this is one of their
songs that they made cuz they do really
make it their own there's a lot of
energy a lot of enthusiasm it's a
spirited performance I've seen a lot of
drummers
you know harmonized before and do backup
vocals I know he's not the first ever to
start just doing a big part of a verse
on his own I know he's not I've just
never seen it until now watch some
videos that's that's gnarly
that seems like the hardest one to play
and sing simultaneously I was doing the
math in my head shouts out to you
Burrage I feel like you could probably
check me on this it's hard enough to
play a guitar and sing at the same time
while you're you know oscillating two of
your appendage
and with drums you're doing all four
plus you're singing so I got imagine
that that's probably the hardest to do
and I'm never not imprint like no matter
how crazy the drumming is or how
intricate the vocals are or not I'm
always impressed by Dromio gets carried
the tune to me it's like trying to do a
square and circle at the same time in
the air you know like singing to the
beat like he's singing to the beat but I
feel like I can't even do this
make a metronome and sing to that it's
like I have to rap to it you know it
takes like a guitar is easier for me to
do that to I feel like a drum would be
way more complicated as opposed to just
doing this yeah see the thing it's like
for me from my experience like I can
sing and play the drums if it's a
relatively simple beat where maybe my
hand and foot are gonna be kind of
hitting on the same note so it's not too
complicated it's just a simple like 2 2
2 2 you know I can probably sing on that
it looks like yes guy was pounding away
though no he's he's a real drummer like
I can do very basic beat but I mean that
was cool to see all three of them
singing for this one you know taking
turns - it wasn't just the ones back up
for this one one's doing Armour like
there's a time where they each took a
turn well that's the fortunate thing I
hadn't thought of it but I was like yeah
it's good you have everyone able to sing
because especially for Broadway you're
gonna need that yeah do a Broadway cover
- you're gonna have characters switching
up and harmonies and things happening
yeah yeah every once in a while it's
nice to watch a very simple music video
just like record them edit around them
just doing their their jam session yeah
I miss though that's what all music
videos used to be for a covers band you
know just out of Manchester or whatever
it doesn't look like the most expensive
video everybody's got freaking music
yeah I got a cool green tint to it the
entire time I don't know if that's his
lights from where they're at or actually
I did that what this is yeah because
wicked hi I just put it together Elphaba
I was thinking they were fans of the
matrix that's who would we get is based
on the meat I think the green is
probably
what's her name diva as Marella Elphaba
I'll turn it really you have a real name
yeah a stupid nail pH makes this show ha
ha you're about to find out in the
comments below
all the Broadway fans who watch are with
you know that was fantastic and Lewis
thanks for introducing us see these guys
that are called boomin that's what I
gather I mean yeah the rest of the title
is defying gravity wicked said they must
be called boomin we are defying gravity
wicked and this is our new single boomin
but it might sound a little you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification Belka subscribe
buttons are broken and you can check us
out on patreon full-length TV show
reactions weekly Q&A is music video
coverage would love to have you become a
patron oject today